today on the matt well show the left has
been sent into spasms of outrage because
of a florida bill which would prohibit
public school teachers from talking to
elementary schoolers about sexual
orientation and gender identity what
kind of creep could possibly oppose a
law like that we'll find out today also
canada descends into full full-on
totalitarianism even as we're told that
putin is the greatest threat to the west
and scholars have discovered that
diversity training doesn't actually
achieve anything so what's their answer
well to do more diversity training of
course in our daily cancellation we'll
talk about the father a 14 year old tic
toc star who shot and killed her stalker
that's the good news the bad news is
that this father allowed his 14 year old
daughter to be a tick-tock star in the
first place we'll talk about all that
and more today on the matt wall show
[Applause]
[Music]
you know as inflation continues it's
important to keep your budget and your
financial goals top of mind think about
the things you can do today to come out
ahead like refinancing your mortgage if
it's not on your
to-do list it should be because you can
be paying a lot less for your home right
now and i know just the people to help
american financing a family-owned
mortgage lender that's known for its
custom home loans and it's no pressure
approach to lending as well from lower
rates to shorter terms and even debt
consolidation they do whatever it takes
to set you up for financial success they
can help you save up to a thousand
dollars a month plus tens of thousands
long term so why not learn more if you
start soon you may get to skip two
payments as well and you could close in
as little as 10 days so you start saving
you start saving very very soon uh
nothing to lose you might as well give
them a call if you want to do that call
866
569-4711 that's
866-569-4711 again the phone number is
866
866-569-4711 or visit
americanfinancing.net american financing
nmls 182 334 nmls consumeraccess.org
so you know much can get lost amid the
cacophony of perpetual phony outrage and
it can be hard to discern any one bit of
outrage from any other you've probably
still noticed over the last few weeks
that people on the left are very angry
at florida
and i mean they're always angry at
florida they're angry mostly that
florida is thriving while they live in
gray dreary cities covered in human
feces and used heroin needles so you can
hardly blame them for being a bit
envious but the professed reason for all
the anger towards florida this time in
recent days has been our particular
piece of legislation called the parental
rights and education bill
now even if you don't live in the state
it's worth tracking the story because
much can be learned from it i think and
especially from the reaction to this
bill so the law would bar schools from
discussing sexual orientation and gender
identity with kids in elementary school
and this has provoked
volcanic fury from the left to have
dubbed the legislation the don't say gay
bill
they claim that this is among other
things an attack on free speech
of course the idea that adults have the
free speech right to have inappropriate
sexual conversations with children
is the kind of thing that you'd expect
only pedophiles and perverts and
predators to argue for
and you would be right
and it's easy enough to understand why
gender identity shouldn't be discussed
in elementary school in fact it
shouldn't be discussed in any grade any
at any level because it's an incoherent
made-up concept invented not
coincidentally by a pedophile mad
scientist named john money who you're
well familiar with if you listen to this
show
gender identity is a religious doctrine
it's part of the left-wing creed it has
no basis in science or reality
now if a christian public school teacher
cannot stand in front of his class and
declare that jesus christ is lord and
savior and all students should accept
him into their hearts
then a leftist public school teacher
should not be able to stand in front of
his class and declare that boys can
magically become girls if they believe
it in their hearts
the left has for years shouted that we
must keep religion out of the classrooms
but as it turns out they only had
certain religions in mind which we've
known for a while but what about sexual
orientation
now it's at least coherence and
factually true to say that a person has
sexual urges which are generally
oriented one way or another in fact um
john money also coined the term sexual
orientation but at least in this case
there's it's it's
it's coherent you understand what's
being said
the question though is whether a
government employee
in the government education system
would ever have any valid reason to talk
to a nine-year-old about sexual urges
the answer to that question obviously is
no
the left says that not only do these
adults have good reason to talk about
sexual urges with prepubescent children
but even that they the adults
have a right to hold such discussions
to force them to refrain from talking
about their sexual urges with children
is to persecute them we're told
moreover it deprives the children of
something that they need
because children before the age of
puberty somehow need to talk about a
topic that they fundamentally won't be
able to understand
and which has nothing to do with any of
the academic subjects that they're going
to school to learn about
this is absurd for a lot of reasons but
the main one is that it goes the other
way around
you aren't depriving children of
something
they need by refraining from having
inappropriate sexual conversations with
them in elementary school you're
depriving them of something you they
need when you do have those
conversations
namely you're depriving them of the
innocence of childhood
now leftists they they actually will
openly scoff
at the very idea of the innocence of
childhood they don't recognize that
there isn't any innocent child because
along with being acolytes of john money
even if they don't know their acolytes
of them they're also acolytes of alfred
kinsey and the other late 19th and early
20th century degenerates who claim that
children are sexual from birth
now that's false but it turns out this
was not a that this was not a
description it was a prescription
children are not naturally sexual from
birth but these quacks would try to
change that they wanted them to be
and they've been trying to change that
fact ever since
and to prevent them from doing so to
prevent the adults from doing that
from sexualizing childhood that is a
personal attack against them
we're told
which should really tell you something
and so should this
outrage was renewed over the weekend
after a new amendment was added to the
bill which according to all the
headlines would require schools to quote
out their students
now the idea of outing an elementary
school student doesn't even really make
any sense to begin with but the way the
headlines are written it makes it sound
like
teachers are required to investigate a
child's sexual preferences and then set
off some kind of alarm you know pull an
alarm and alert the whole building if a
kid turns out to be gay
yet investigating sexual preferences is
exactly the sort of thing that the bill
forbids
that's what they're not supposed to be
doing
so the framing doesn't really make any
sense here
it turns out
when critics say outing
what they mean is that schools are
required to inform parents
and there's a difference there
so here's the article from the hill
it says a new amendment to florida's
don't say gay bill would require schools
to inform parents of their children's
sexual orientation within six weeks of
learning that the student isn't straight
nbc affiliate wfla reported on monday
the amendment was filed friday by the
bill's co-sponsor state representative
joe harding the bill which has gained
national attention and pushed back bars
educators in florida from talking about
sexual orientation or gender identity in
primary schools parents would be able to
take legal action against school
districts that they believe have
violated the measure
the original version of the legislation
required schools to inform families of
their child's lgbtq plus status but gave
an option for exemption for the outing
in cases where educators feared it could
lead to abuse neglect or abandonment the
amendment offers no such exception
yes it offers no such exception
because any such exception would
guarantee that no school would ever tell
any parent anything
because they could always simply claim
that they fear abuse at home
and this is especially true given that
the left considers it abuse
if a parent fails to accept that their
son is really a girl
or
that their girl is really you know a
non-binary pansexual chipmunk or
whatever
the point of this amendment
is not that schools ought to be digging
into a child's personal life and then
reporting back to the parents
that's close to the opposite of the
point
the point is simply that the schools
that would be the government
institutions
should not know more about a child than
his own parents do
i have a right to know
what my child is doing at school what
he's saying how he's behaving
how he's quote identifying
there should not be any secrets kept
between students and teachers
there especially shouldn't be any sexual
secrets kept between students and
teachers
only in a culture fully succumbed to
madness could that concept be at all
controversial
now the reason that parents should know
this information
is that they have a right to know
my child is my child
i have a right to this kind of knowledge
about him
especially if it's knowledge that other
people have about him
but the other reason is that teachers
can't be trusted
and there are great many examples that
could be marshalled to prove this point
but here's just the latest this is i'll
play for you a local news report out of
a california school district about the
sleeping arrangements at a recent
science camp listen
micah the parents tell us that their
children came home from camp they were
asking a lot of questions about gender
and pronouns
the parents then reached out to the camp
director who told them that counselors
biological males who identify as they
them are permitted to spend the night in
cabins with the young girls
in the parking lot of weaver elementary
school in los alamitos a group of
parents no parent should feel the way i
feel after knowing what could have
happened to my daughter upset by the
sleeping arrangements at a school
organized science camp i contacted the
school and i asked them if they were
able to confirm that there was not a man
actually sleeping in the same cabin as
the girls
they were not able to confirm that the
parents say their fifth grade girls told
them some of the biologically male
counselors at camp ali in san bernardino
identified as they them and spend three
nights sleeping in cabins with the young
girls they're asleep they use the shower
they
go to the restroom camp pally confirms
per california state law we place staff
in cabins they identify with
now the uh the
parents would go on in that clip to to
stress that they're not they're not
accusing
uh the male adults uh the the teachers
of doing anything they're just saying
that they're uncomfortable with the
sleeping arrangements they're not making
any specific accusations
uh they're not they're not claiming for
example sexual abuse but um i think that
they ought to claim sexual abuse because
that is sexual abuse
in and of itself
even if no even if nothing else happened
other than what we're being told
for male adults
sleeping with 10 year old girls
that is abusive sexually
in and of itself
without the parents knowing
but they can do it because they identify
as they them
and this is supposed to make them less
of a threat somehow
by some incoherent grammatical
technicality
they discovered the right to have a
slumber party with elementary school
girls at science camp
the question is whether you trust these
sorts of people to have sexual
conversations with your children
do you trust them to have secrets with
your children
do you trust them at all with anything
well
obviously you shouldn't
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know with the ever-increasing
numbers of makes and models and
everything else it's impossible to stock
all the parts you need in a traditional
chain storefront for your car so why
endure often pointless or seemingly
intimidating questions about your the
specifications of your vehicle only to
have the guy behind the counter or
counterman as he's called for whatever
reason order the parts on his computer
anyway there's no reason to do it cut
out the middleman you have access to
rockauto.com at home in your pocket just
pull out your phone and go there why
would you choose to spend 30 50 100 more
for the exact same auto parts at a chain
store or new car dealership uh not only
that but you're paying more for uh for a
lower for a less inferior selection of
items as well rockauto.com is a family
business they've been serving auto parts
customers online for 20 years you can go
to rockauto.com right now to shop for
auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers they have everything from
engine control modules and brake parts
to tail lamps motor oil even new carpet
whether it's for your classic or your
daily driver they've got everything you
need and also they're going to deliver
it directly to your door rockauto.com
catalog is unique and remarkably easy to
navigate quickly see all the parts
available for your vehicle and choose
the specifications you prefer best of
all again prices at rockauto.com are
very low so go to rockauto.com right now
and get their amazing selection and see
all the parts available for your car
truck right walsh in there how did you
hear about us box so they know that we
sent you
all right so we had uh we had off for um
a president's day that's why you know we
weren't here yesterday i don't know why
we had offer president's day president's
day is a is a stupid holiday you know it
made sense when it was washington's
birthday but then they expanded it to
include all presidents and it just lost
its meaning because you know american
presidents apparently are quite
sensitive and and we don't and they're
needy you know they're like their own
victim group and we can't leave anybody
out we have to make sure that
everybody's included
um we can't just celebrate washington's
birthday because then the other
presidents are going to say what about
me i want to be celebrated too
what about you
i'll tell you about you a lot of the
rest of you sucked that's why you don't
get your own holidays or you shouldn't
anyway
i mean why should we let somebody like
bill epstein clinton
ride washington's coattails to the
holiday just doesn't make any sense
but now we're giving out participation
trophies to presidents apparently and uh
it's dumb but i'll take the day off
that's that's the lesson
actually they came to me last week
and they uh they actually asked me they
said do you want to take the day off
because everyone else is getting the day
off do you want that day off also and i
said uh yeah like what kind of person do
you think i am of course i'll take the
day off
if a day off if a day off is on the
table i'll take it
i mean eventually they'll declare you
know the official george floyd memorial
federal holiday
and i won't like it but i'll take that
day off too
i'm a man of principle and one of my
principles is that there is no bad
reason to take a three-day holiday it's
one of my primary principles in life a
guiding principle i would say
all right so
after um developments in eastern europe
over the weekend
the war drums are beating even louder in
the united states um and when i say war
drums are beating louder i mean
especially among the establishment or
really only among the establishment that
would be the media the elites the left
i haven't met very many or any regular
citizens who are anxious to send their
children off to bleed on foreign soil in
defense of some country 6 000 miles away
i think our appetite for those kinds of
adventures has been considerably dulled
over the last two decades
so i haven't really met anyone who
actually wants to do that but the media
the elites to left the neocons
their lust for war cannot be satiated
mostly because
they're not the ones fighting the wars
they reap the benefits but they pay none
of the costs and so in that case
especially if you're a soulless
sociopath it's easy to be in favor of it
because you get all the benefits and
none of the costs
and so they make the case that your
children should die to protect ukraine's
borders
even as these same people oppose so much
as erecting a wall to protect our own
border
that's reason enough right there to
ignore everything they say about this
in fact i think that should be the first
question anytime anyone is telling you
about what we should be doing to protect
ukraine's border you should cut them off
and say well what about our border what
do you think about that
and if they have any hesitation saying
that we should protect our own border
then just ignore them
their opinion is not valid
but people who won't even utter the
phrase american sovereignty
now would happily plunge us into world
war iii for the sake of ukrainian
sovereignty
i have heard and seen people on social
media who i i have i have never heard
these people ever talk about sovereignty
as it relates to to the united states
in fact they would say that if you care
about american sovereignty you're a
you're a
uh you know it's
ethnocentricism it's nativism it's white
you're a white nationalist
and yet these same people are are
talking about oh the rights of
ukrainians to the sovereignty of their
nation
there are lots of reasons to disregard
what these people say but i think this
their their pathological hypocrisy is
definitely one of them
another reason
is that
we have major problems of our own in
this country
and that's not what about ism
and even if it is by the way there's
nothing wrong with a what about argument
it's like actually a very valid
only in this stupid day and age do we
consider it inherently fallacious to
make an argument that starts with the
phrase what about
but this is actually an important thing
to point out here
if anyone is advocating something that
could lead us into war into a major war
um i think it's valid to say well yeah
but there are other problems that we
need to
be addressing
and this might detract from our ability
to address those other issues so our
cities look like third world countries
our borders our sieves our own our own
sovereignty is threatened our freedoms
are being erased
our children are under attack as we
discussed in the opening
our civilization is actually imploding
so excuse me if i don't give much of a
damn right now about
ukraine
and we also have along with everything
else um our own fascist dictator right
across our own border
and that would be justin trudeau so
here's from the daily wire the latest on
this ottawa police chief steve bell said
during a press conference over the
weekend that canadian law enforcement
officials would continue cracking down
on those who participate in the trucker
protests well after the protests have
ended
the revelation came in a response to a
reporter asking if there were going to
be repercussions down the road for the
protesters even if they'd retreated and
gone home and the answer was yes let's
listen to that um answer from the police
chief
i'm andy now
i'm from independent media so i was in
the crowd yesterday um i was
unfortunately hit with some pepper spray
i just have a question uh
there's some video cameras that the
police are using
and some news outlets that reporting
that you're gathering intelligence with
those cameras can you elaborate like if
the protesters at this point uh you know
uh retreat and go home
uh are they gonna be getting sort of
repercussions down the road are you
gonna be sort of actively pursuing the
people that you've been sort of
documenting and filming who are still
out there protesting what are your plans
after this after the protest is over
tonight it's a great question and the
simple answer is yes
if you are involved in this protest we
will actively look to identify you and
follow up with financial sanctions and
criminal charges absolutely
this investigation will go on for months
to come it has many many different
streams both from a federal uh financial
level from a provincial licensing level
from a criminal code level from a
municipal breach of court order breach
of court and junction level it will be a
complicated and time-consuming
investigation that will go on for a
period of time you have my commitment
that that investigation will continue
and we will hold people accountable for
taking our streets over
hold them accountable uh long after it's
done gonna hunt them down we're familiar
with this um
we've seen similar things play out in
the united states um
against right-wing protesters of course
not against blm not against left-wing
protesters holding held entire cities
hostage for months on end burn down
buildings everything else attack police
officers
nothing like this but we've seen it
against the right-wing protesters
and we're going to see it in canada and
one of the reasons is that these people
are all
you know on top of being
dangerous right-wing radicals we're told
they're also
uh nazis
so here's canadian mp yara sax
and uh she has uncovered kind of a code
a message some symbolism hidden within
this protest
and um anyway let's let's listen to her
explain it
how much vitriol
do we have to see of honk honk which is
an acronym for hail hitler
do we need to see by these
protesters on social media
my god
first of all it's heil hitler not hale
hitler and also that's not what an
accurate that's not what the word
acronym means
honk honk is an acronym for ohio hitler
this is how desperate they are
um
after the fact
but we also know what the crackdown
itself uh which we should note that the
crackdown itself you know began before
this when they sent cops in to disperse
the protesters and at one point uh maybe
you've seen this video but we'll play it
again if you haven't seen it the cops on
horseback started trampling the protests
so let's play this
just going right over top of them
trampling right over top
of the
protesters not making any attempt at all
to go around them
right through the crowd what is this
lady doing traveling traveling horses
i think multiple people
there you go
right over the top
now important note that these people
they didn't like dive in front of the
horse
which would be a really stupid thing to
do they were already standing there
and the cops said we're just going to go
right over top
and they know that they can get away
with it
um nothing like that you they couldn't
possibly get away with anything like
that if these were left-wing protesters
but in this case they they can and they
have
no accountability whatsoever
this is why one you know going back to
the
putin in russia situation
i've seen
a lot of people saying that hey you know
the united states we need to be uh the
leaders of the free world
and that's why we have to step up to the
plate and defend ukraine
against this ruthless dictator
because that's our um
that's our calling that's our vocation
as the leaders of the free world and
i've seen this phrase written
you know many times over the last few
days as it relates to russia
but i see that i think well
what do you mean
leaders of the free world where where is
that exactly
who who lives in the free world right
now
when canadians certainly don't
is that what the free world looks like
where if you engage in a protest they're
going to trample you under horses and
then freeze your bank accounts
and hunt you down and punish you that's
what the free world is
if that's the free world
then there is no free world
anymore
now you can make an argument that the uh
free world uh had basically ceased to
exist before covet but certainly now now
two years into this
after the free world has shown the
ability and the willingness to shut down
all all freedoms all liberty
um
you know including closing churches
ending
uh your first amendment rights
any any of your rights could just go out
the window
if they claim that they have an excuse
to do it and and
their excuse for tossing our freedoms
out the window it's the same excuse used
by
every tyrant in history nothing new
about this
oh it's for your good it's for this it's
for your safety it's to keep you safe
it's the same thing every tyrant in
history literally has said
while they're trampling under your
trampling your your freedom freedoms and
sometimes your skulls
under uh their foot and their hoof
so after the last two years especially i
i'm not sure
where the free world exists
but i don't see how we're the
representatives of it anymore
um and that's all the more reason why
it's kind of absurd to argue that we
should plunge ourselves into world war
iii for the sake of defending the free
world where where is that
what is that
um
okay moving on
while all this is happening and uh we're
told that you know we are potentially on
the cusp of a of a major global conflict
let's see what our leaders in this
country are up to alexandria
ocasio-cortez uh she decided to put this
on instagram live over the weekend
because she's a she's a little bit
stressed out by by everything going on
and uh just it's very stressful to be in
congress
for some reason even though you only
work like five weeks out of the year and
everything else but um she's very
stressed out about it
and so she decided to film herself
dunking her head into ice water
for whatever reason let's watch that
ready when you are okay
five
four
good job good job
am i supposed to do it again yeah you're
supposed to keep doing it really how
long like multiple sets
okay go for as long as you can actually
livestream this
to
why all right
you know uh
the last time i was on tucker i said
something about how
you know we can't underestimate the fact
or understate the fact that we're being
led by really stupid and and
unimpressive people
and he made the point that um it's it's
actually a really good thing that
they're so stupid
because can you imagine
we've seen the kind of damage that they
can cause
being dumb tyrants but if they were
actually smart if these were evil
geniuses
can you imagine the situation we'd be in
right now
so i mean you gotta look for silver
lining wherever you can find it and so
i'm choosing to find to see that as
silver lining
that this is how dumb these people are
at least they're dumb
you got to give them that at least
from the daily wire it says scholars
recently admitted to forbes that annual
diversity equity and inclusion dei
trainings aren't very effective that the
solution should be more woke ideology
the college fix reported that
traditional anti-discrimination
trainings conducted on an annual basis
aren't sufficient and studies show it
but instead of looking for reasons why
the training isn't actually effective
and that perhaps the content needs to be
changed or presented another way those
scholars insisted that people simply
must be subjected to the training more
often
the forbes article explained that quote
a lack of understanding regarding issues
like the bamboo ceiling
what
the bamboo ceiling
hair discrimination
tone policing
colorism which i guess is supposed to be
distinct from racism i don't know and
experiences of first generation
professionals inhibits an organization's
ability to cultivate inclusive spaces
i feel like i have to read that again
because i didn't understand what i just
read and it probably won't be any better
the second time but lack of
understanding regarding issues like the
bamboo ceiling
hair discrimination tone policing
colorism and the experiences of first
generation professionals inhibits an
organization's ability to cultivate
inclusive spaces oh okay yeah i still
don't understand um donna dockery a dei
expert an adjunct professor at hunter
college told forbes that annual training
ends up with situations where quote the
people who usually need it the most and
usually the ones who who
are usually ones who do not value it and
don't show up
dockery then argued that once a year was
not enough for these trainings
they're also commonly done once a year
or reactive to something bad which comes
off as disingenuous dockery added make
your dei efforts a priority make it a
part of your annual budget it should be
ingrained in your work activities these
trainings need to be ongoing
so they're doing these uh well first of
all hold on i gotta look up bamboo
ceilings i don't even know what that is
i'm gonna guess
i'm afraid to even guess
because if i'm wrong i'll be accused of
racism but i'm gonna guess this is some
sort of anti-asian discrimination i'm
going out on a limb and guessing that's
what it is um
and okay good yeah that's what it is um
the term bamboo ceiling was coined in
2005 by jane hoon
in breaking the bamboo ceiling career
strategies for asians this is according
to wikipedia by the way my number one
source for everything where she
addresses the barriers faced by many
asian americans in the professional
arena such as stereotypes and racism
while also providing solutions to
overcome these barriers
the bamboo ceiling as defined by jane
hoon is a combination of individual
cultural and organizational factors that
impede asian americans career progress
inside organizations are you kidding me
now if you wanted to tell me
that the bamboo ceiling is affirmative
action
which penalizes asian asians and
especially asian students for being so
gifted and so hard working
and then you have institutions saying oh
we don't need as many asians because we
need more of other races so if that's
the bamboo ceiling you're talking about
then um then fine i'll i'll go along
with that
i i think i'd probably prefer a
different term than bamboo sealy but if
that's what you want to call it that's
not what they're saying though
um it doesn't sound like this is like
they're singling out affirmative action
as the problem they're saying this is
this is like a systemic racism thing
where asians are being prevented from
achieving career success
what
what in the world
in america you think that's happening
asians have the the number one median
income
on average
if you were to rank average income by
race asians are at the top above white
families um asians are you know
one of the great success stories in this
country
they're
vastly overrepresented in fields like
medicine and engineering
and if if we can still claim that even
asians are the are somehow being
suppressed by this systemic racism again
unless we're talking about affirmative
action which they aren't
but putting that aside
um
if even asians
an enormous success story in this
country now are also victims and are
running up against some sort of ceiling
and supposedly their ceiling is even
harder to break through than anybody
else's
because at least women have a glass
ceiling
now you could bust through that pretty
easily you might want to put a helmet on
but a bamboo you have trouble busting
through that
yet there's a bamboo ceiling and yet
asians do fantastically well in this
country they do better than anybody
and yet they're still a ceiling stopping
them no okay
um
but overall
we're being told that uh
they've noticed at least so they got
halfway there they've noticed that
they're doing all this dei training
and uh it's not achieving anything
at all it's not helping anything
and but their solution of course as
always is just to do more of the thing
that isn't working and also to make it
mandatory
in the land of the free remember
because they have noticed that uh yeah
well if you make it voluntary then the
only people who will voluntarily subject
themselves to this are the ones who are
already brainwashed no one else is going
to sit through it and so now you have to
force them to do it and so do it more
make it mandatory it's not working
that's that's the problem they've
identified
and the solution do it more and make it
mandatory
great idea
uh from breitbart it says former
president donald trump's social media
app that he hopes will rival twitter
launched on monday as he seeks a new
digital stage to rally his supporters
and fight big tech limits on speech a
year after he was banned from twitter
facebook and youtube his truth social
app was uh offered for download from the
apple app store to a limited number of
subscribers who had pre-ordered others
who were added to a waiting list are to
be given access over the next 10 days
uh apparently there was
you know apparently there was a
some problems with the launch and so
most of the headlines about this are
gloating over the fact that um
that
the website went down or something when
they were launching it
but i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
gloat over that obviously because i
think it's good it's it's a good thing
to try to attempt
so i can admire that and any any of
these attempts to create an alternative
platform to twitter
uh we need people like donald trump to
do that we need people who have the
money and the resources and also have
the it helps for him that he that he has
the um the name recognition obviously
he's like the most famous person in the
world so he's if anyone can make it work
from a branding perspective you'd think
it would be him and maybe it will work
i hope it does
my only issue and i say this as someone
who i haven't used truth social i didn't
get an invite myself i wasn't one of the
vip invitations so i haven't seen it
all i've seen is some of the screenshots
and everything
and from the look of it it would appear
that truth social is um
like pretty much every other right-wing
alternative to twitter
it's it's based on twitter it's just
it's trying to make the right-wing
version of twitter
and as i've been saying for for months
it's just that's not going to work
you no matter how much money you
have or how much brand credibility or
name recognition you're not going to be
able to out twitter twitter
because they've been doing it for a long
time they've got billions of dollars
you're not going to be able to make a
better version of twitter what you
should do instead is make something else
entirely
and so the one thing that's been and
it's a major thing but the one thing
that's been lacking from all of these
attempts at making a kind of right-wing
answer to twitter is uh innovation
creativity you know there's nothing
innovative about it
so that's my first question anytime i
hear about one of these new platforms is
what's different about it
what's the innovation
how is the experience you know actually
substantively different
and so far
the answer has been well it really isn't
maybe that's different with truth social
from what i've seen it doesn't seem to
be but but you know i hope that that
will change
okay finally bill gates um continues to
be for whatever
reason trotted out as a as an expert
on covid and so here he is at the munich
security conference over the weekend
talking about masking listen
what about masks i think there are a lot
of people in america who are confused
about whether they should be wearing a
mask and in the united kingdom for
example they've scrapped that all
together well that's interesting you
know what is the downside of wearing a
mask i mean it's got to be tough you
know you have to wear pants
i mean this is tough stuff these
societies are so cruel why did they make
you wear pants i'm trying to figure it
out
we're very glad you have yours on um
that will be on the web
will be on the web
they're still using that line it's in
there and they're never going to abandon
it it's just like wearing pants and he's
so
for whatever reason because this this
scumbag
and he really is
but for some reason he's he's a software
salesman basically and uh but yet he's
brought on to talk about cover no one's
ever explained why
all this emphasis on oh we got to listen
to the experts wasn't how is he an
expert what what what is his area of
expertise exactly how does it relate to
covet viruses and vaccines
um
but he's still up there laughing at the
idea uh what's what's the problem with
wearing masks
well if you
were to take a second and do you know i
don't know a minute of research bill
gates you you would discover that there
are a lot of significant problems that
are being suffered primarily by kids
and so developmental delays
uh depression all this kind of thing all
these kinds of things
that's that's one of the problems
but to bill gates with his billions of
dollars it's all it's all quite
hilarious so we can have a good laugh
about it great
let's get now to our comment section do
you know their name
okay dailywire.com sweet baby comments
if you want to leave a video comment
let's start with uh seven was the 7a
hey google
i'm straight
i'm sorry to hear that i think you're
awesome and you are not alone i hope i
can be an ally to you and there is help
if you need it
hey google
i'm gay
thank you for telling me being true to
who you are is a beautiful thing do you
have what you need to live your identity
fully
yes
you're awesome and beautiful what's not
to love live life proudly
that is that
is that real so that's google
oh well that's google's version of siri
or whatever if you say i'm straight it
will answer i'm sorry to hear that i
need other people to test that i need
that to be confirmed
because that's kind of that's a story
right there
we're breaking news in the comment
section
from a sweet member of the sweet baby
gang on the matt wall show
um so i need to
here we go what is this and this is this
is the google assistant this is the
transcript said i'm gay thank you for
telling me
okay so that's the traffic
other people if you have this google
assistant thing
try it out for yourself
confess your sexual orientation to
google
if you feel like doing that and let me
know let me know what the results are
all right um let's go to clip 9.
ma'am that's just a boy with wood spoons
in his mouth
but if i believe that they'll say
homophobic
protecting your son ma'am that's most
heroic
thank you matt walsh for writing this
book that i can share with my son
we hope that you write others that we
can add to our collection
fcg for life
well thank you ma'am for uh making sure
to indoctrinate the kids very young
at six month old you know it looks like
he's about six months old i could tell
that he was really into it he understood
what was going on and if you want to get
your copy of johnny lawrence you go to
johnnywalrus.com and order today from uh
from amazon
and get the lgbt children's book
best-selling sensation if you have not
gotten it yet all right let's go to
laura says thanks matt because of you my
husband now walks around the house
saying he identifies as brilliant and
handsome
well i'm humbled to know that i've
inspired
your husband and so many others to live
their truth and embrace their identity
so thank you for telling me that
um
mick says you've always been a back the
blue type but do the events in canada
make you rethink your loyalty to the
police at all
well first of all i certainly wouldn't
describe it as loyalty to the police um
loyalty is something that i have to my
family to my wife you know
not to government employees so that's
that's not the word that i would use
but does it make me rethink broadly my
support for police in general no it
doesn't
um
number one this this these are this did
happen in canada so it does seem you
know sort of unfair to blame american
police for that although we've seen
we've seen scenes not quite that bad as
it pertains to covet but almost as bad
we've seen that happen in the united
states as well there's no doubt about
that
so how do i respond to that
well the police involved in that kind of
thing and crushing people's civil
liberties
and um hunting down and punishing you
know people who haven't done anything
wrong who are just expressing their
rights
you know those police deserve to be held
accountable
and deserve all the scorn coming their
way
and they absolutely cannot hide behind
the uh well i'll just i'm following
orders i i have to do it or i'll lose my
job i believe that
i believe if you're sent out and told to
tamp down this protest of people who are
tired of the coveted tyranny if you if
you refuse it you'll lose your job i
could believe that
but there are times in life that call
for courage and this is one of those
times
if you fail to heed the call then you're
a coward
so that's my response to police who do
that
but does it mean that um
i don't support police in general no
because i don't even know what that
means exactly you know the people who
are critical
of police in general and i've seen even
some people on the right especially over
the weekend in response to this to what
was happening in canada say oh you know
i'm not back the blue anymore i don't
support police
well what what's the other option
i mean i i
assume you agree that there needs to be
we need to have laws
you know we don't want to embrace
anarchy
we see what anarchy looks like we get a
taste of that in cities across the
country with da's who well there is a
law but they don't enforce it
and so it's anarchy and i assume that
that's not the situation you want across
the entire country so we need to have
laws
and as long as we have laws they need to
be enforced because again we know what
it looks like when they're not enforced
you might as well not even have the law
which means we need law enforcement
officers
people who are in charge of enforcing
the law
when they do the wrong thing again we
should criticize them heavily
hold them accountable
but we still need people to do that job
and the ones who sign up to do it i mean
it's not a job i want to do
especially in this environment
so it's a job that i recognize must be
done
and no one has ever suggested an
alternative all the defund the police
everything
no one has ever said what's the
alternative we don't have police what we
have instead
no one's ever been able to answer that
question any attempt to answer it has
been absurd laughable
they're the ones who talk about oh we
have social workers responding
when there's a shooting we'll send the
social workers and therapists in there
to make sure everybody's uh
doing okay psychologically it's absurd
because there is no alternative
so i recognize that it's a job that
needs to be done
it's a job i sure as hell don't want to
do
and so yeah i appreciate the people who
are signing up to do the job that needs
to be done and i don't want to do
i think most of them tried to do it well
and um and so i support them the ones
who abuse that authority
i do not that's kind of how i how i
break it down it's not very complicated
um
let's see
jj mack says i'm late to the show sorry
you made a point about victimless crime
when it relates to transgender sports if
the women speak up they could lose their
scholarships
you don't think that's why they're not
speaking up more
well i'm sure that's why it goes back to
the situation with the police yeah if
you try to do the right thing
you're going to suffer consequences and
that's the case for everybody no matter
your station in life
that's just well it's always been the
case in life especially these days
but if you
are determined to do the right thing
in any situation there can always be
consequences
and the more dire the situation the more
dire the potential consequences but
that's that's what courage is for we
can't just give up on courage
you know if we're saying that oh yeah we
expect people to do the right thing
unless it's difficult and they might
suffer consequences for doing it
then what you're saying is we don't
actually expect anyone to do the right
thing because doing the right thing when
it's not difficult and there are no
consequences well anybody could do that
so yes um i fully believe that uh
girls who
refuse to take part in this charade they
could suffer consequences
i still expect them to speak up because
it's the right thing
and especially if you want us to care
about women's sports
and you're in women's sports and you
want us to defend women's sports well
then you're you have to defend it also
you're in it you're the closest to it if
you won't defend it then then why should
i
and the other thing is that yeah if one
or two um women speak up against this we
know what will happen to them because
some women have spoken up and they get
they get just
devoured
right
um the hounds descend and rip them to
pieces but
if if all the women or even half of them
or even like a a solid
large minority were to speak up and
refuse to participate
then um you know they can't all suffer
the consequences
so
or the institutions could try to make
them also consequences but they won't be
able to sustain it
let's see uh
manic pixie fan girl says okay yeah
maybe a bill of rights for dogs and cats
seems silly and extreme but we can't go
on allowing the types of abuses
perpetrated on these animals to continue
without consequences some of us
conservatives are animal lovers too
this was a really weird take and not a
hill to die on in my opinion
now wait a second pixie fan girl
california has a bill that claims dogs
and cats have a god-given right to live
in comfort and luxury that was part of
the bill
and that this right only extends to to
domesticated dogs and cats and no other
animals
and i'm the one with the weird take
if you say so
america is under attack and the threat
is coming from within that's why we're
exposing just who is destroying american
institutions and why the enemy within
began streaming exclusively at the daily
wire last week and features acclaimed
journalist and expert in national
threats lee smith as he uncovers a
political coup orchestrated by america's
ruling elites to generate their own
wealth and power at the expense of the
american people's safety and freedom the
groundbreaking breaking first episode
should be required watching for every
american affected by the coveted
regulations which is in fact everybody
in it smith reveals shocking details
about both anthony fauci's role in
hiding critical information from the
american people as well as the
unanswered questions surrounding the
origins of the virus check out the
trailer here
what if everything we think we know
about our leaders
our society and our relations with the
rest of the world is wrong
america is facing two major challenges
one is the chinese communist party
however the most significant threat
comes from within as you're trying to
obscure responsibility for four million
people dying around the world senator
paul you do not know what you are
talking about
we've already seen evidence of how the
elites want to run the united states
they're modeling themselves after
chinese autocracy for over a decade the
people's republic of china
has stood publicly accused of acts of
cruelty
and wickedness
that match the cruelty and wickedness
of many evil torturers and executioners
dianne feinstein
had a chinese spy as her driver for 20
years we're not talking about
one person infiltrating senior levels at
the cia or the white house we're talking
about an entire elite class
throughout the political corporate
academic cultural and media
establishment my name is lee smith i've
been a journalist for more than 30 years
this is the most astonishing espionage
and infiltration operation in history
what you're going to see in this series
will shock you
this
is the enemy within
[Music]
the enemy within is streaming now
exclusively to daily wire so if you're
not a member now is the time to change
that head to dailywire.com subscribe to
join us today and also you know there
are many excellent books too
controversial for your average publisher
but not the daily wire that's why we
started our own publishing wing called
dw books we're proud to be publishing
two books that are actively fighting the
left's monopoly on storytelling the
first is 12 seconds in the dark by
sergeant mattingly the book is the true
story of what really happened the night
of the tragic brianna taylor shooting
mattingly a 20-year police veteran takes
readers inside his department's response
and debunks the lies that have
recklessly been shared with the public
dw books is also publishing fiery but
mostly peaceful by julio rosas who pulls
back the curtain and sets the record
straight on the black lives matter riots
that broke out across the country 2020
roses who was reporting from the ground
gives his first hand experience at the
riots and exposes the media's attempts
to convince americans that the fatal and
destructive riots were somehow peaceful
i'm so grateful to have these brave
truth-tellers on board and i can't wait
for you to hear their stories both are
available for pre-order now on amazon or
anywhere you buy books now let's get to
our daily cancellation
[Music]
you know for most of the history of
human civilization before tv before
movies before media before the internet
every country or society would produce
only a very few famous people
you had to achieve something or be
someone of incredible significance to
earn fame so the famous were all kings
and conquerors and explorers and all
that sort of thing each generation would
have maybe a famous artist or two maybe
a writer a philosopher an inventor an
innovator so fame was a very rare
commodity
and famous people belong to an extremely
small and exclusive club for everybody
else on earth fame was basically
unattainable and i imagine that most
people didn't spend a lot of time trying
to think of ways to attain it because
the average person
was known only by the people that they
knew
and the idea of being known by lots of
people you don't know which we might
call the definition of fame would
probably not have seemed terribly
desirable to the average person during
this time
but
then tvs came along in hollywood and the
media and the ranks of the famous
swelled considerably suddenly you didn't
have to do anything significant to
achieve fame you just had to be good at
pretending to do significant things
that glowing box in the living room gave
you a window through which you could
peer voyeuristically and the people on
the other side of that screen were all
famous because although they knew they
were being watched they didn't know most
of the people who were watching them
this made fame a little bit more
attainable
um and and yet still only a relative
handful would ever attain it
but it did make fame much more desirable
even for those who would never attain it
because the non-famous were spending so
much of their lives watching the famous
and envying the fake lives they lived
inside that box
and then the internet came along
and social media close behind it
fast forward a generation and now a
measure of fame can be had by anybody
with a twitter or tick tock or instagram
account
we're all famous now to one degree or
another
we are all known by people who we do not
know
we present ourselves as objects to be
viewed and we hope envied
some portion of people will experience a
greater amount of this kind of fame
but nobody is required to achieve
anything or be anyone or do anything or
have any skill whatsoever to be famous
anymore you don't have to be a conqueror
or king you don't even have to be a
decent actor
you just have to offer yourself up as a
spectacle
and others have to take you up on your
offer even if it's never quite clear why
they find your offer appealing
this is just one of the one of the
myriad reasons why kids should be kept
off of kept off of social media because
although they might deeply desire to
make their lives into a spectacle for
public consumption that desire is not
healthy
and we should do everything we can to
prevent them from fulfilling it for as
long as we can
because there are a lot of downsides to
fame
but those downsides used to be balanced
by the fact that at least the famous
people were all by definition talented
and accomplished
modern society however provides the
opportunity to experience the downside
of fame without any of the upside
a lot of mediocre people become famous
for no good reason and then are promptly
consumed by this fame that they never
earned or had any business experiencing
it's kind of the equivalent of lottery
winners who are destroyed by their
wealth must much more quickly and more
consistently
than people who earn their fortune
through skill and hard work
paraphrasing jeff goldblum in jurassic
park the lottery winner has wealth but
it didn't require any discipline to
attain it
and the same could be said for fame on
the internet we're all sort of
attentional lottery winners
we all get much more public attention
than we really weren't and it didn't
require any discipline to attain that
attention
and that after a long preamble brings us
to the subject of our daily cancellation
as the daily wire reports
quote the ex-cop father of a 14 year old
american girl who has over 1 million
followers as a tick-tock star shot and
killed an 18-year-old boy who stalked
his daughter and had traveled hundreds
of miles to her home where he fired a
shot through the family's front door the
father was not charged under florida's
stand your ground law ava madri 14 whose
videos show her singing dancing or
pulling pranks
noticed in early 2020 that one of her
followers eric rohan justin 18 of
ellicott city america maryland
was becoming obsessed with her messaging
her in snapchat and instagram and even
joining online games that she played
with her brothers according to new york
times ava initially responded to justin
as she did with other fans but learned
that he was buying her personal
information including her cell phone
number from her friends in new jersey in
florida and then he would call and text
her with the number
okay now to be clear
we're not canceling ava because she's
only 14 certainly can't be blamed for
any of this we also aren't canceling
eric rohan justin because he's dead
anyway and it would be kind of redundant
his cancellation has already been
handled it would seem instead we're
canceling ava's parents
now her dad should be commended for
shooting the predator but that's really
where the commendation ends
aside from that one bright spot
her parents have played a pretty dark
role in this story as we'll see
continuing
it says ava's parents allowed her to
sell mr justin a couple of selfies that
she had already posted to snapchat the
times noted continuing after that mr
justin messaged ava on venmo with a
breakdown of what he would pay for
booty pics and photos of her feet quote
unquote stuff that a 14 year old
shouldn't be sending she said
she blocked him on all her accounts in
venmo
messages viewed by the times mr justin
pleaded with her to unblock him mr mr
madrid the father said he texted mr
justin's cell phone told him that ava
was a minor and demanded that he stop
contacting her
now you've hopefully already noticed a
number of red flags where the parents
are concerned starting with the very
fact that ava is a 14 year old tic toc
star
there's no such thing as a 14 year old
tic toc star with good parents but we
haven't even gotten to the biggest red
flag of all yet back to the article it
says
since the incident michael moreno an
entertainment lawyer created agm
creations for ava she is now represented
by washington lawyer lonnie davis and
his public relations firm
ava is still on social media and her
parents support the idea her mother
claimed that she did not want ava to be
forced off by sick individuals saying
why should we allow them to stop her
maybe she's meant to bring awareness to
all this
ava said that at night she has doubts
about continuing social media but by the
morning's quote i thought of all the
benefits most people would say the money
and yeah it's a huge benefit but it's
the experience i got to go to la the
people that i met just being able to
make other people smile is what i like
the enjoyment of seeing the impact i
make on people's lives i post a video at
night close my eyes in the morning it's
exciting to see how much how many views
i get
rob madgery echoed quote it's like
christmas every day because then you see
it build i think we just had to allow
her to make a decision and sort of
support her i think it's going to help
her heal it sounds corny but i don't
know what else you could do for it
okay sure dad your adolescent daughter
has been traumatized by the experience
of a gun-toting psychopathic tick-tock
fan blowing her front door open with a
shotgun and the way to help her heal is
to allow her to make more tick-tock
videos
now let's back up and review the whole
scene for a second
a 13 year old girl
wants to open a tick tock account
her parents allow it
she begins amassing a huge army of male
followers who all enjoy watching her
dance
her parents continue to support it
an adult male stalker takes a very
special interest in the girl and her
parents her parents allow her to sell
pictures of herself to this person
then that same individual shows up at
the house with a shotgun
the dad dispatches him his one good act
in the whole story and immediately
allows his daughter to get back on tick
tock and continue building her brand
now with a lawyer and a pr firm behind
her
now ava says that she you know she wants
to continue because the good outweighs
the bad
what's the bad
well for one violent stalker is trying
to murder her that's that's one bad
thing
what's the good well she likes seeing
how many views she gets on her videos
there would seem to be something very
wrong with ava's scale and i know what's
wrong with it she's 14.
no 14 year old can appropriately weigh
the good against the bad and
consistently make reasonable decisions
based on that calculation
i couldn't at that age
that's why the child needs her parents
to view the situation from a vantage
point that is inaccessible to her
they're supposed to be bigger and not
just physically able to see farther down
the road
but all these parents can see it would
seem are dollar signs
and that makes them especially gross and
negligent but compared to other parents
who let their young children pursue
social media fame they're worse only by
degree not by kind
though today we're focused just on them
and to them we must say you are both
canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens production manager pavel
voldowsky the show is edited by robbie
dantzler our audio is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is done by
cherokee heart and our production
coordinator is mckenna waters matt wall
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 22.
today on the ben shapiro show vladimir
putin declares two separatist control
regions of ukraine independent and sends
in the troops and the biden
administration backs away from harsh
sanctions that's today on the bench
bureau show give it a listen